american belief in god has hit a new low  and this is a story i've done so many  times on my youtube channel because just  about every year american belief in god  hits a new low  this is not a huge shock because this is  the the trend line this is the way that  things have been going and i think the  the one caveat here  is that there still are plenty of people  who report  being spiritual to some degree and what  everybody means by that might differ but  a belief in like a personal god or the  sort of god of various scriptures  whether it's christian or muslim or  jewish or whatever the case may be  that does continue to decline over time  what's not changing is that the  religious right still rallies behind  particular issues including abortion and  gay marriage and that a whole bunch of  money can be raised  in opposition to those things but belief  in god itself continues to decline is  this surprising let me know in the  comments